Hi there. Welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan,
also known as Rawkode.
Today, we continue the complete guide to Kubescape.
I wanna say thank you to the team
at ARMOR for sponsoring my time to put
this course together.
Kubescape is a phenomenal tool that helps us
improve our security posture and our Kubernetes cluster.
Do I think it's hyperbole when I say
every cluster should have Kubescape installed?
No.
So let's take a look at how we
continuously
monitor
our security posture.
When you run Kubescape,
you get the ARMOR cloud dashboard.
You can go and see
the report and results
of all your scans.
But we're developers and operators and we like
Grafana and dashboards and metrics.
So how do we get our Kubescape control
failures into a format that we can work
with with our automation?
Well, as we've seen in a previous video,
the Kubescape CLI accepts a format parameter.
We took a look at a
JSON.
There's also HTML,
pretty print,
and JUnit.
The last option is Prometheus metrics.
So first, we're just gonna take a very
quick look
at the Prometheus metrics output.
Then I'll show you how we do it
in production.
We run an operator and our cluster
that uses Prometheus
service monitors,
speaks to Kubescape, gets a result of our
scans,
writes them to Prometheus,
and to finish it off, there's even a
Grafana dashboard
to take a look and understand what's going
on.
So this will be a quick video, but
there's a lot to love. So let's take
a look. So the first thing that we
want to do
is run a Kubescape scan
dot.
This will scan our local directory,
find Kubernetes manifests,
and give us a report.
As you can see, we've got resource limits
that need specified
and oh,
some host page IPC
and network privileges.
Well,
that doesn't sound too great, does it? And
of course not. We take a look at
the YAML.
I have enabled these three things. Why?
Just to give us something to visualize on
a dashboard as we improve our security posture.
So let's see the Prometheus
metrics output
from the CLI.
We can run the scan again. This time
we set format equals
Prometheus.
And as you can see,
we get a whole bunch of Prometheus style
metrics written
to the terminal.
You could script them into Prometheus
somehow,
but there is a better way.
So the first thing I'm going to do
is run this just target called helm.
This is gonna set up all the repositories
that we need for today's session.
Next, let's list the targets.
We have one for helm that we just
run. We have installed Grafana,
installed Kubescape,
installed Kubescape Prometheus,
and installed Prometheus.
So let's do
Prometheus first,
All by Grafana.
All by Kubescape.
Prometheus.
And then by the power
of video magic,
we will have a complete setup.
Now before I click my fingers, the just
fail is here and available via the repository
on the Rawkode Academy. The link is in
the description.
Go check it out if you wanna see
what's happening.
Alright. Let's run kubectl get pods all.
We have Grafana.
We've got Kubescape,
Kubescape Prometheus,
and Prometheus.
So what's happening right now is that the
Kubescape operator is running in our cluster.
It's continually scanning and and monitoring
our resources.
Let's run
kubescape control minus n
kubescape
Prometheus
get
service monitors.
And we can see that we have a
service monitor
and a namespace.
So, let's browse to Prometheus.
We can run kubectl minus n, Prometheus
port forward and we're gonna go to the
service,
kubescape Prometheus
stack.
Prometheus
on port nineteen ninety.
So we pop up on our browser
and we have the Prometheus UI.
We can zoom in on this and we
can start to type Kubescape as a prefix.
From here, we can select our cluster risk
store
and hit return.
And we'll see that we have
a score of 12.
So let's take a look
at one more metric. Kubescape
framework
can't failed.
Now we have a breakdown of the number
of failures per framework.
If I zoom in on this more,
you'll see all control 36,
ARMOR best 22, DevOps best nine.
Now this is a fantastic resource of information,
but it's not readily consumable
in this format. Right? This is why we
have Grafana to help us visualize our dashboards.
Again, as I said in an earlier video,
it's through visualization that we build understanding.
So let's go check a look at Grafana.
We can run kubectl
namespace Grafana
get secrets.
Why? Well, because Grafana helm chart generates
a random password and we'll need that to
log in to the instance.
We grab the Grafana secret,
a YAML,
and we run a base 64 decode
of this value
here.
And now we have our secure
password.
Now we can run kubescape control namespace Grafana
port forward
for service Grafana.
And we'll expose this on port 3,000,
although the service does listen on port 80.
Now if we go to 3,000,
username is admin and the password is the
one we got from the secret.
And now we have a Grafana dashboard.
So we need to go to settings and
data sources
where we can add our Prometheus source.
Now we're just used in regular Kubernetes service
discovery to hook this up.
That means that we use the service name,
which was kube
stack
Prometheus.
The namespace,
which is Prometheus.sec.cluster.local,
and the port is nineteen ninety.
We click save and test,
and it tells us as an error.
Your Prometheus,
stack Prometheus,
and that is working.
Alright.
Let's go to the explore tab
and take a look.
Use the Kubescape prefix,
and you can see that we have access
to the cluster account
based on resources and controls. We have a
cluster risk score, which we can run.
And we'll see as remain pretty static.
That makes sense.
Bring back our Kubescape prefix,
and then we have a control account resource
and a framework account resource, but not at
the cluster level. So probably broken down by
namespace,
and, of course, our risk score here.
Let's take a look at Kubescape
framework
count control
failed.
This should give us a breakdown of the
different controls
by a namespace
that have failed.
Assuming if we go to name,
we can filter by the framework.
So we can see ARMOR best
like so.
Let's try
one more.
This time, Kubescape
control
resource failed.
And now we can filter this by name,
and we're going to find the host PID
IPC
privilege.
Like so.
Now we can see that this is slowly
claimed as I've deployed some example resources to
the cluster.
So let's pop back to our YAML,
and we'll remove two.
Like so.
Let's look at the last five minutes
and run the query.
Alright. So after a little bit of time,
we see
that our resource failure dropped from three
to two.
Now
Grafana is a great tool. Prometheus is a
great tool. I've been able to query individual
metrics and view them as a graph is
also great.
Sometimes
you just need a dashboard.
We need to see multiple queries, multiple metrics,
and how they change together
over time.
So
let's run
the download dashboard,
just target.
From there, we can cut the dashboard and
copy it to our buffer. We can then
go to the Grafana homepage,
import dashboard where
we could paste in the JSON.
From here, we click load and we import.
Let's change the time to five minutes.
Now there is a bit of a small
bug with Grafana and that our dashboard, no
matter how many times we click refresh, won't
seem to load.
However, I found if you just go to
edit
and multiply the query ever so slightly and
click run,
it seems to jog it back into touch.
However, we do need to do this
for all the panels.
Like so.
So while we've only changed one resource, we've
not really affected our cluster risk score,
and that is kind of expected.
And you can monitor your controls over time.
As we can see from this, we have
a lot of controls,
and we can see there has been a
change,
but it's difficult to pinpoint which.
Now we know which control was affected, so
we can scroll down the alphabetical list
until we find
host.
Host. Host. Host.
Lots of controls. There we go. It click
host path to IPC privileged.
And now we can see that drop on
the resource over time. On the right, we
can see our framework risk score over time,
which again much like the cluster score is
unlikely unlikely to change by fixing one resource.
And then we have a good overview of
our two pie charts.
We can see the resource status and control
status, but this time not over time, more
as a an overall picture of our security
posture.
So we could see actually that 74%
of our resources are passing their controls.
So we actually don't have too
much to do.
However, when we go over to the control
side,
we can see and I'm not sure why
it's green,
the 43%
of our controls have a resource that are
in violation,
which is why we see so much activity
on the control risk score.
So now we have all the information that
we need to do two things.
One,
monitor and observe our security posture.
You might be in good shape now, but
as developers are deploying to your cluster, these
things change over time.
So it's great to have Kubescape in your
cluster with Prometheus and Grafana. You can build
alerting rules just like you would for all
the other parts of your infrastructure.
And number two, you have a way to
track and celebrate progress.
Make sure you're identifying
the controls that are important to your organization.
Even build a custom framework. Go check out
that video next. And that's it. I hope
you've enjoyed this tutorial on Kubescape with Prometheus
and Grafana. I'll see you for the next
video soon. Have a great day.